over the last 12 months I've gotten the
opportunity to work with over 15
multi-million doll e-commerce Brands and
I've noticed these five huge mistakes
that almost all of them made in their
email marketing so whether you are an
e-commerce brand looking to increase
your retention revenue or whether you're
a copywriter who wants to serve
e-commerce Brands as clients this video
is going to be massively helpful for you
because not only am I going to tell you
the five huge mistakes that e-commerce
brands are making but I'm going to tell
you how to fix them as well starting
with mistake number one sending heavily
designed emails e-commerce brands are
treating their email campaigns like
their mini websites every single week
but the problem with these heavily
designed very beautiful emails is that
they're often times flagged by Gmail
Yahoo and now Apple too who's adding
promotions tabs increased filters and
Spam folders stronger than ever because
of the amount of frequency that people
people are sending these emails so these
beautifully designed emails are actually
not even getting seen by most of your
clients and even if they are getting
open now you have to overcome the
problems of like image loading or even
just somebody actually clicking the
links and enjoying the email itself
which sounds crazy because when's the
last time you got an email from a friend
that was flush with a bunch of designs
and images never because it looks like
an ad so it feels like an ad so they
read it like an ad so they archive it
and trash it immediately it's just bad
all around instead here's what you can
do is you can ab test plain text emails
that's right just like Grandma opened up
Gmail and started typing and hit send
because that's what feels personal
especially in 2025 when advertising and
email marketing has hit an all-time high
you have to get in that primary inbox
you have to fix that deliverability and
plain text emails is the first place
that we start in fact my email micro
agency drives fitterman and Co have done
this for over 20 e-commerce Brands and
every time we tear down those sexy
little pixels that all these designers
put up and we start sending PL text
emails Revenue goes up without a doubt
sidebar if you are interested in working
with me directly on your email Ecommerce
brand there's a link in the description
below for my micro agency dragu
fitterman and Co you can go in there
apply to work with us and if your
application goes through we'll do a free
audit for you before you and sign up so
super easy hit the link in the
description below if you are an
eCommerce brand mistake number two is no
offer to join your email list I've seen
this time and time again where sometimes
e-commerce Brands don't even have a
popup and yes I know they're annoying
but goodness do they work and so why
would you not Implement that even if it
annoys certain people so not only should
you put a popup you should make a great
offer a lot of e-commerce brands are
like join us for insights and exclusive
deals or join the fam like none of that
works okay people are already on too
many email lists they don't want your
stuff unless you give them an offer to
join it so something as basic as 10% off
your first order or a certain amount of
dollars off your first order just put
your email in below and we'll send you
the coupon code fantastic that gets you
their email so that you can sell them
later if they don't buy right now
mistake number three is not having the
essential clavio flows you need to have
these seven essential flows set up a
welcome flow an abandoned cart flow a
postp purchase flow a browse abandonment
flow a winback flow a VIP flow and a
sunset flow once you have these in place
then you could start AB testing what's
working and what's not working but at
least get those seven in place so that
you can make money while you sleep
people are naturally going through email
sequences so you don't have to just rely
on campaigns mistake number four is too
many ctas in your emails again we get
these beautifully designed emails and
they're like broken out in sections like
it's like shop for this are you
interested in this watch our YouTube and
blah blah blah you have too many call to
actions one email to one person to one
call to action rule of one simplifying
that will actually increase increase
your clickthrough rate which will focus
your customers to do the one thing you
want them to do which is buy order right
you want to increase your order so when
you have them watching YouTube videos
and all kinds of other stuff in your
emails you're distracting them from the
one thing you want them to do simplify
strip back to the essentials and focus
on one call to action per email mistake
number five and this is the most
underrated mistake that I see all
e-commerce Brands make making and that
is never telling stories always just
trying to sell this is a huge underrated
problem where even as you're hearing me
right now you're like I don't understand
what he's saying let me tell you
consumers have become immune to Super
salesy discounts and Deals email yes
they still do work but it doesn't build
a personal connection with your brand
which means that the next time another
brand similar to yours comes out they
have no relationship to continue to buy
from you they'll just go to the better
product or the cheaper product or
whatever it is because you've not told
any stories they don't know who you are
they don't know anything about your
brand the founders and people are
relationally and emotionally connected
to stories so when they connect with the
founder when they connect with your
day-to-day operations through great
storytelling they actually become
significantly more loyal to your brand
and this increases the lifetime value of
the people on on your email list so most
Ecom brands are just worried about
average order value getting a bigger
average order value but you miss the
entire point if you're not increasing
your lifetime value the amount of
reorders and rededication and loyalty
that your customers are already giving
you the best way to do this is by
telling stories so let's recap what
we've already learned and what you need
to be doing one ditch the heavy design
emails and test a plain text email two
create a compelling offer and a pop-up
form on your website three set up the
seven essential clavo flows for revenue
on autopilot four stick to one clear
call to action per email and five tell
more stories and listen if you found
this helpful and you want to work with
me and my team again hit the link in the
description below click dragu fitterman
and Co and you can get our free 53 Point
audit for your e-commerce brand I
personally do it with my business
partner Ben fitterman we done tons of
these for huge Brands so I know we can
knock it out of the park for you but if
you are a copywriter who's wanting to
implement this for e-commerce Brands
then you can join my email list at Allen
dru.com for more tips like this on how I
can teach you to become a better email
copywriter appreciate the time thank you
so much and I look forward to chatting
with you soon